et on commence donc cette matinale par
ce rassemblement plutôt étonnant aux
états unis des centaines de personnes se
sont retrouvées à dallas persuadé du
retour du fils de l'ancien président
john fitzgerald kennedy qui lui est mort
depuis vingt deux ans oui c'est vrai
résultat d'une théorie sur les réseaux
sociaux et cette affirmation john
fitzgerald kennedy junior va
réapparaître et remettre donald trump au
pouvoir le souhait de nombreux texan qui
se sont déplacés et largement bloqué
depuis pour leur crédulité les
explications thomas bonnet
l'image a été reprise abondamment dans
les médias souvent pour pointer le
ridicule de la situation la scène s'est
donc déroulée ce mardi à dallas dans le
texas des centaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées sur les lieux où a été tué
le président john fitzgerald kennedy en
selon ces personnes s'appuyant sur une
prophétie circulant en ligne le fils de
l'ancien président allait faire une
apparition et ramener donald trump à la
maison blanche précision importante gfk
junior qui est donc le fils de l'ancien
président américain est décédé il y a
maintenant 22 ans dans un accident
d'avion mais pour les personnes qui se
sont rassemblées à dallas la croyance
était tenace d'écouter son plan a été
mis en place en mettant en scène sa
propre mort sauver l'amérique peut
sauver le monde
je pense que s'il fait une apparition
aujourd'hui il passera en voiture je ne
pense pas qu'il sortira parce que nous
n'avons pas de sécurité ici il ne va pas
se trouver dans une zone ouverte sans
sécurité personnellement je ne le ferai
pas des propos tourner en dérision pour
pointer l'absurdité de certaines
théories qui circulent en ligne car
évidemment jeff keay junior ne s'est
jamais montré et les participants se
sont à disperser sous la pluie à texane
mais des responsables politiques
prennent la faire plus au sérieux et
l'interprètent comme un symbole d'une
déconnexion d'une partie des américains
avec la réalité c'est en substance ce
qu'a écrit sur twitter un sénateur du
connecticut
il est en fait plus largement question
du mouvement tuân anh qui rassemble des
nombres aux internautes autour de
théories discuter sur des forums avec
donc des messages énigmatiques posté par
un certain coup avec une spécificité
dans le cas de ce rassemblement qui
s'est déroulé à dallas puisque les
messages n'ont pas été publiées
directement par ce cube qui en 2008
avait d'ailleurs affirmé que jeff keay
junior était bel et bien décédé